[Musique]
ce vendredi au sein de l'hémicycle du
département le cnar mme marques et la
réussite de sa dernière opération de
recrutement 174 jeunes réunionnais
partiront prochainement travail en
métropole 9 cdi 138 contrat de
professionnalisation et 27 contrats
d'apprentissage ont été pourvus grâce à
la mobilité et la mobilité
c'est un projet de vie mais c'est aussi
le meilleur moyen de continuer à se
former pour mieux revenir dans son
département dans son île natale partir
pour se former et acquérir des
expériences renforcer ses compétences
cette extraordinaire mais avoir cette
possibilité de revenir est aussi
formidable et nous aurons besoin de
cette jeunesse formée de cette jeunesse
conquérante ici à la réunion
pourquoi on a choisi de partir mobilité
alors parce que tout simplement ici j'ai
remarqué que
a pas beaucoup d'opportunités et que le
marché du travail il est fermé le mot
est le mot est clair un c'est fermé
parce que moi je suis titulaire de
certains diplômes et
mais avec ses diplômes l'art qui sont
forcés qu'ils sont bien cotés et nous
n'avons pas de suite à nos entretiens
deux fois six entreprises
métropolitaines avaient fait le
déplacement pour cette opération de
recrutement
le comité national d'accueil et
d'actions pour les réunionnais en
mobilité favorise l'insertion par la
mobilité en métropole et à l'étranger
nous avons autant d'offres d'emploi de
la part des entreprises de métropole il
ya deux raisons principales la première
secteur métropole contrairement à ce
qu'on pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'emplois
libre et la deuxième saison est pourquoi
nous ont dit que les réunionnais étaient
des personnes sérieuses poli agréable et
donc de la réputation de la réunion est
bonne et je dis aux réunionnais bravo
parce que vous portez aux efforts de
couleurs depuis le début de l'année huit
cent quarante quatre postes ont été
pourvus en métropole et à l'étranger
grâce à l'action combinée du cnls armes
et du département de la réunion
[Musique]